The Joe Rogan experience
mean easy to live with.
But it's interesting that this
is like this game of like, okay,
let's look at watches. There's no real
improvement in performance, right?
I mean they're beautiful and,
but I mean the performance difference
between now and 10 years ago is not clear.
Yeah. In a mechanical watch.
No, I mean it's their watch.
There's artistry and there's
technological complication. I mean it's,
there's complication for
the sake of complications.
So they'll have watches
like to use a car example,
imagine a car. Okay.
And from the outside it looks roughly
like a normal car, right? Four,
four wheels on the driver's seat, right?
It has one engine and it has four
transmissions coming off of that engine,
all of which come back
together to make it the car.
One wheel drive. [inaudible] right.
Imagine that applied to a watch.
So it'll be like one main movement that
goes out into four gear trains and then
comes back into just an hour
and a minute hand. Well,
why would you sync up for gear trains
when you could do the same thing with one?
And it's like, well, because we can,
it would be like building a car with
two engines. Like that's not smart,
but you do it just be like, Hey, I
built a fucking car with two engine Les,
you're talking about
like the NSX engine. We,
you're the front engine for
the electric. Exactly. Exactly.
But I think what I'm getting at is
that with computers and with cars,
those are the one thing that you
expect an improvement every year. Yeah.
Just that nobody's going
to accept the old way.
Like you can't just build unless you're
singer and you making something custom.
Well that's that the singer
is what that example is,
what the mechanical watch
kind of industry is. You know,
they,
they position it as a luxury item
from a time gone by sort of thing.
You know? Whereas actually if you
want to talk about innovation,
this right here is a grand Seiko,
which has a movement called a
spring drive movement in it.
And it is one of the most advanced and
unique mechanical movements available in
a watch today. So this is a Seiko,
it's a grand Seiko, which is,
so the difference is uh, it's
like, think about a Lexus.
Think about Alexis. A Seiko
is a Lexus, not a Toyota.
This is a Lexus LFA.
This is a grand Seiko is built in a
different factory from the regular Seikos.
It's built by hand, completely by
hand, all hand finished, hand polished.
It's built of exotic materials.
It has a cool movement. Dude.
You should sell watches or watch
podcasts, but watching, listen,
it's on YouTube,
but you see I have what is
called the display back on this.
So you can see the movement in the back
and how high the level of finishes.
And you've got Sapphire, titanium and um,
so the spring drive movement is without
getting crazy crazy nerdy about it. Is,
is actually a true innovation
in mechanical watchmaking.
So run the chronograph,
it's on the front. The top
button not here at you watch the,
the sweep of the chronograph
hand, the big second hand,
you get a perfectly smooth sweep.
The smoothest possible sweep that
there could be. It is, it is,
it is, it is. How much does
the watch like this worth?
Around 10,000 yeah. Mazing yeah. God.
But it's watch $300.
Well that's cause you know G shocks
are the shit dude. 300 bucks.
G shocks are awesome as far as like
I'm a light. No, but it hasn't,
but it's polished so that it can see
it in the dark date. Motherfucker.
Look dude, G shocks are dope.
A G shock is a watch guys tool
watch like highly functional,
durable. Um, a G shock is
a total watch. Guys watch,
you can get G shocks that are like $5,000.
You know what? Yeah, they have dude,
Jamie look up a $5,000 G shock. That's
um, that right there. Hold that up.
That's Sean Warren Ward's
own design. That's cool.
It's amazing as I think it's
based on the Duesberg. Yeah.
Duesenberg gauge cluster. The
watch is called the doozy and it's,
it's got a complication on it
called the jump. Our complication.
So the,
it's a basically just a black face almost
looks like a bathroom scale and it's
got two windows hours on top minutes
on the bottom and the minutes sweep by
slowly.
Whereas the hours do not suite
by slowly at 59 and 59 seconds.
The hours click over right fast.
So it's a jump power as
opposed to a slow moving hour.
Now he designed the look or
did he design the internals?
He designed the look, the face,
the complications and he worked with a
Swiss watch maker to design an actual
unique movement to use for this watch.
He designed the case and that's crazy.
It is awesome. And that watch is
12 grand. I was making 50 of them.
I believe it. He tried to use the
face in that a Vantaa black shit.
What does that Phantom
black is the darkest,
the blackest black that
has ever existed. Oh,
I saw they painted a building with it.
It looks like a negative space, dude.
Get a picture of to black.
It doesn't look real and it's
the most black that that,
that that's something painted
in Vantaa black. Whoa.
It's so black that it absorbs all
light and you can't even wait.
Can you paint a car in that you could
accept in the environmentally? It's not.
It's not a good thing.
Fuck the penguins. Oh,
whoever's going to die
apparently to me black G wagon.
Oh fucks bro. I need
my G wagon. [inaudible]
has the Vantaa has Vantaa black
and of course it does and it's,
you'll see it's $95,000 and the Vantaa
black is just the black background.
When you said $95,000 my balls hurt.
Me and my balls go like
this. They went, bro.
They got watches that are $1
million. There's $1 million.
You can buy $1 million watches
right now. 300 bucks. G shock dude.
There's a watch called the Jacob astronomy
that is like wearing like a Sapphire
fishbowl on your fucking hand. I swear.
It's the craziest shit you've ever seen.
It's so ridiculous. It's
like Liberace. The oil sheet,
Zay and Jamie top right picture
there. See this as a gold case.
That's a Sapphire case. The whole
thing. What if you bump into something,
it's shattered on your hands. That's
so stupid. Well, glass was not glass.
It's Sapphire Cinderella motherfucker.
The whole case is milled
from a block of Sapphire.
The whole case can go fuck
itself. Seriously. It's $1 million
you deserve. You deserve that thing
to break. That's crazy looking.
It's hilarious, right? That's $1
million watch. Earth is the earth. The,
the planets are spinning around,
spin around and you can find a video of
it moving. It's nuts. Look at the stars.
Oh, it's kinda like a roll of
you drove your rolls Royce.
It would match our watch.
You'd be like, Whoa, Whoa.
You could coordinate this guy
with your star field ceiling dude.
That is a small earth.
That's crazy. And it's,
it literally has the continents and
silver and then some blue star thing.
What is the water made out of?
You think it's gotta be like,
I so idea anodized something,
but then there's a diamond,
a son on the other side of my God,
there's a ball at diamond ball that
spins or some of them have different,
different, uh, stuff on them too,
that that's just one ball or you have
to be to be sporting $1 million water.
That one's got up, that
one's got a central,
let me check the time on my million
dollar mother fucking watch. It's crazy.
Right? That's crazy. There's some
rich people doing some really,
really weird rich people things
right now. That seems preposterous.
That thing with all the diamonds in the
bucket diamonds, that's like some steam,
punk, futuristic, but like, it's weird.
Even more so than you know, cars. It's
like, cause a car, it's like, okay,
you got a thousand dollar car
cut $10,000 car, $100,000 Carmen.
Like when you use the
zoom in really close,
that's the computer version
because that's not, Oh, it's CGI,
but that is pretty much what you get
astrological signs there. Oh my God.
What is that the red made out of?
That's like Amber something. Oh,
probably Ruby. The sons a
Ruby. It's probably Ruby.
The sun's probably a yellow diamond
mother fucker. That is incredible.
I don't get it, but I get it.
I know you must've.
I'm able to appreciate that someone is
making a machine that fits in a little
fishbowl on your wrist. Look
at that it again and look.
I mean look on top of the crazy artistry
of this and the ridiculous price and
the jewels and all that stuff. The
mathematics of that machine work.
That is not, that's not
just like that for nothing.
That does like moon phase.
You know the what sat
astrological sign. It is.
There is an actual function. Look at
that one with the dredge dragon in it.
You gotta be fucking kidding me.
It looks like something to come out of
a little kid's gumball. It's so crazy.
Right? Go scroll up.
That's amazing. Looking.
Scroll up to the other images though that
they had those three watches together.
Look at you ever. Look how good
those things look. I mean, that is,
that is a crazy thing to have on
your arm. It's so crazy, right?
But that's $1 million. And if you see
someone wearing one in person, it's,
it's big. It's, it's like,
it's like the size of,
you know that that Ganny lid
coffee mug in your hands.
It's so big. There's really,
people are there actually,
I mean you'd be shocked at what
people are doing with certain,
with machinery and watt and mechanical
watchmaker wouldn't be mercies.
It's like the fight against
friction is the whole thing, right?
You've got this tiny little spring and
you need to get as much power out of it
as possible.
So they engineer these like micro
grams of friction out of this stuff.
So they they let's not ER work
the fuck is that star Trek?
Yeah. And uh, Whoa. That's pretty, yeah,
I think it was the lid liquids closed.
It looks like an egg
star Trek communicator.
Now how much does something like that go
for, let's call it 50 or 60 Oh, sorry.
I was going to, yes, I
was going to get higher.
I was going to get 75 I think you can
get different versions of it that are,
don't hold me to the price.
It's expensive, but what
do you think it cost Jamie?
Take 75 yeah, that's what I was saying.
75 let's top the top
article should have it.
The hoe dinky article
usually has the price.
If you scroll down to the bottom
of that article, it should have it.
That's it closed right there. So you
can read the time when it's closed.
So that on that watch
it's eight 27 Oh yeah.
And what does it look like when it's
closed? Go, go up. That's close, right?
That's closed. Yeah. And then that's
another version of different tops. Yeah,
the clear top or the
the or the metallic one.
And then there's a carbon back
and that's a pretty watch. Yeah,
it's pretty looking. If you scroll all
the way down, it should say the price.
No, 68,000 there you
go. Fucking expensive.
It's, there's some wild stuff. There's
a company called H, Y. T that is,
that makes watches that have a liquid
that moves around and it tells you the
time based on like almost
like a thermometer. The
liquid goes up to this level.
There's a watched by a company
called Devin, D. E. V. O. N.
it's a belt driven watch where you have
like a series of conveyor belts on your
wrist. There's the HYC. So the green,
the green liquid goes around the dial.
Ah, yeah.
It's like a nuclear ooze that
like flows through the dial. Yeah.
So it, it changes depending upon
the time. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So that,
that GU like it flows.
Go back to the one with the
green goo on the top left there.
So all my light fills up around the dial
and then it is when it goes all the way
around. Is it a minute? Ain't no,
it's an hour. That belief. Amazing.
It's awesome. Right? That's amazing.
You looked down and that's how
you know where it is in the hour.
And then it had a, it had a typical
hour hand. Yeah. And then this one,
it flows around the skull. Dude.
This something like that costs a
hundred grand or something. Geez.
Actual Rose is actually sponsored by
them. Believe it or not. It works. Right?
It's on brand for him. I think
this is about a hundred grand.
So when you say sponsored, like
what do they do to get axle to wear?
He wears one. Yeah. I follow these
dumb watch spotter Instagram accounts.
They sell for upwards of 50,000 so I
think it's more than that. But yeah,
50 or 75 yeah, they're expensive man.
It's David Cross selling watches.
285,000 days.
Three particular ultra light
high-end model. Which one's that one?
But it's there's, you know, there's
some materials in this stuff there.
They use crazy forged carbon there.
Well I'm 95 grand used for a skull
one. Yep. Ooh, let me see that.
That's pretty, Oh bear real crazy. I mean
it's, you can get lost in this stuff.
I mean the machinery of it and
the materials. Do you think the,
the liquid is that goes
around that fuck? I dunno.
They may have a different
picture with a different liquid.
So that's how the minutes go.
Yeah. And then there was an allies,
so crazy the press that, let's see,
here's the liquors, the liquid going
so cool. That is fucking dope. I just,
I love the fact that
people are so creative,
they can figure out how to do things
like this on something like a watch.
So you look at the look of the red
dude going around the skull. Ah,
isn't that awesome? Oh my God.
I'm in love with it. It's so cool.
It's amazing. I'm in love with this. And
then look, it goes back, it goes back,
but it goes back quick. It goes
back quick and resets. Oh wow. Yeah.
Eyes fill up when it goes
back. Oh, you gotta be kidding.
Oh my God. That's some really next level.
Like there's bellows and pumps and it's
like pumping like liquid around dude.
Right. I had no idea. Yeah, I know.
I did. People were doing this dude.
People are doing crazy
things that is fucking bad.
Like on a more, so that's
really crazy. It's like,
so I have a watch that is
called the perpetual calendar,
which is like a traditional complicated
watch. So it does day of the week,
date of the month, month of the year,
four digit year moon phase. Power reserve.
Okay. And the time obviously, and
it has all of those functions.
And if you, if you keep the watch
running, you know it's mechanical,
you've got to keep it wound up.
If you keep it wound and running,
it will be accurate for all of us.